and back to that breaking news story UK
Deputy Prime Minister Dominic Crabb has
resigned he's been under investigation
following formal complaints about his
behavior Rob was previously accused of
bullying dating back to when he served
as foreign minister and Justice minister
well Sonia Gallego joins me now from
London for more on this and well this
has been a long and convoluted process
can you just walk us through What's led
up to this
well yes I mean the process has taken
about five months and it went into
extraordinary detail in fact top lawyer
was recruited to look into all the
various allegations into Mr Rob's
Behavior and the report itself goes into
those details uh on Thursday there was a
lot of of pondering the the report in
fact the results were expected uh
yesterday and they landed on the Prime
Minister Mr sunak's desk yesterday but
clearly there was an awful lot to go
through them the detail is understood to
be quite a lot but Mr Rob did say that
if any of the complaints were to be
upheld then he would indeed resign
initially he seemed to resist that but
it seems now according to that two of
the complaints in that report have
indeed been upheld in a letter to the
Prime Minister Mr Rob did state that he
remains supportive of Mr sunac and the
government but the fact of the matter
remains that he does feel that this was
perhaps unfair to him as he stated this
inquiry has set a dangerous precedent
now it's no secret that there has been
animosity between certain uh arms of the
government and the Civil Service certain
politicians cabinet ministers within the
government have in the past refer to the
Civil Service as being the great blob so
that has really instituted a sort of of
a culture of animosity between these two
very crucial arms of the government but
the allegations that were placed against
Mr Rob were serious indeed there was
serious allegations of bullying of
intimidation staff was said to have felt
really bullied some feared going into
the office and some even had felt so ill
and were unable to do their jobs and
this situation had caused a lot of
concern as to how workable this
situation would have been in fact if Mr
Rob had not not resign then members of
the Civil Service had said that they
would have resigned and said so either
way it would have been a difficult
situation in this case uh Mr sunac has
had his work done for him by Mr Rob uh
giving offering his resignation but
perhaps you know it's going to be a
double-edged sword for Mr sunit because
Mr Rob was an extremely close political
Ally of the Prime Minister indeed he was
one of the first ones who went out to
bat for him when he went for the job of
prime minister he's going to be quite uh
for still within the government still
has quite a lot of ties within that top
part of the government who was of course
Deputy Prime Minister so it remains to
be seen whether he'll be able to remain
silent on this issue as he goes from the
front benches of the government what
implication is there for the Prime
Minister I mean what happens now for for
Rishi suneck and how does he I guess
stop the The Fallout and the damage from
this
well that's an interesting question
to acknowledge the fact that this is the
third cabinet ministerial post that has
been uh there's been a
standing down from in the past six
months we had first Gavin Williamson who
was the former education secretary who
was again forced to stand down because
of uh bullying and intimidation reports
as well another Minister was also forced
to back down as well because of
questions surrounding his tax Affairs
the third one this is going to present
very much a challenge to Mr sunac as
well these were key figures Mr Mr Rob
was indeed a key figure he he was
relying on him and his experiences just
as secretary to try and push through
certain
laws that were in place regarding the
small boats legal Affairs of refugees
coming to the island as well he was
relying on his knowledge and in this
respect so this is going to be quite
problematic for for Mr sunac and of
course we can't forget the fact that
there is going to be a general election
uh coming in into the next year or
expected to be Mr sunak is going to need
all the political allies that he can get
and he's going to need tough ones a
question remains also exactly how many
of those tough political allies strong
ones like Mr Rob are going to be left in
the cabinet who are going to be able to
pursue Mr sunak's agenda with the same
ferocity okay thank you so much for that
that's on your Gallego for us in London